en un segundo intento por cambiar su
Constitución el gobierno de izquierda de
Gabriel Boris ha llamado a lecciones
para elegir a los integrantes del
Consejo constitucional el cual deberá
redactar un nuevo texto de la Carta
Magna después del fracaso de septiembre
del año pasado cuando un 62% de los
chilenos rechazó mediante un plebiscito
el primer borrador constitucional
Obviamente que también hay un consenso
dentro de los chilenos de una nueva
constitución y ese consenso mayoritario
es lo que nos tiene en este segundo
proceso constitucional y trata de
escribir Ahora sí una buena alternativa
puede ser algo que está claro y que
aprendimos con el rechazo anterior es
que nadie se cambia algo peor los
críticos han dicho que el primer texto
era demasiado largo y con poca Claridad
ahora 15 millones de chilenos están
llamados a elegir 50 candidatos entre
una lista de 350 en la lección de este
siete de mayo Esperamos que más haya de
que el voto es obligatorio y todos
tienen que concurrir a las urnas a votar
se entienda la importancia de votar
informadamente no se eligen a los
consejeros y consejeras constitucionales
que van a deliberar sobre la propuesta
de un nuevo texto constitucional para
Chile luego de la elección de los
delegados se espera que se conforme
oficialmente el consejo para que empiece
a trabajar en el nuevo texto para
posteriormente presentarlo a los
chilenos y que se ha votado para su
aprobación o rechazo en diciembre